so yesterday I did a video on Captain
Marvel and all the amazing powers that
she has and then at the end of the video
I asked you all if you thought that
these powers that Captain Marvel has are
enough to defeat Thanos now obviously
right now Thanos has the Infinity
Gauntlet and obviously what the Infinity
Gauntlet comes basically unlimited power
a lot of you gave your input which I
really enjoyed reading and I really
appreciate you being involved and you
made some good cases for Captain Marvel
for Thanos for Captain Marvel beating
Thanos with out the Infinity Gauntlet
but it seems like the majority rules and
that Captain Marvel really doesn't stand
a chance or anyone doesn't really stand
a chance against Thanos if he has the
Infinity Gauntlet with all of the stones
so after reading all of your comments I
went back and I read the Infinity
Gauntlet series for like the millionth
time and it really does give a perfect
example of just how strong the Infinity
Gauntlet
is not only that but just how strong
they knows himself is without the
Infinity Gauntlet
I mean at one point he literally just
backhands slaps Captain America and
kills him that's not the Infinity
Gauntlet
that's Thanos that's the a Knossos power
so combine that with the Infinity
Gauntlet and all of the Infinity stones
there's really no chance for anybody I
know a lot of people don't read the
comics so I'm just gonna kind of go over
the Infinity Gauntlet series where if
Thanos uses his power and uses the power
of the Infinity Gauntlet so we start off
with Adam warlock getting together a ton
of superheroes to fight Thanos and
Doctor Strange sends them all to Thanos
his base camp that's like a little
palace floating in space and he sends
them all to fight him so Thor Iron Man
Fire Lord and namo are the first to
attack Namor charges at him Thor just
throws this hammer at him Fire Lord
shoots fire atom and Iron Man shoots an
energy beam Adam and Thanos with the
snap of his fingers
stops time so not only are their attacks
frozen but they're frozen also
so Thanos wielding the Infinity Gauntlet
can basically predict everything that's
going to happen before it happens but in
order to impress Lady death Thanos is
convinced that maybe knowing everything
that's going to happen wouldn't really
impress her since it's kind of like
cheating so what he does is he cuts
himself off from this power so then he
snaps again and timer zooms and a few of
the heroes manage to take him by
surprise but unfortunately it doesn't
really do anything to him and this is
where he just starts killing everybody
Thanos simply touches she-hulk and Namur
with the Infinity Gauntlet and kills
them with a space fungi for a brief
moment
everybody thinks Wolverine kill Stannis
by shoving his claws right through his
chest but Stannis has the Infinity
Gauntlet
and uses it to not only recover himself
but turn Wolverines bones into rubber he
kills the Scarlet Witch with laser beams
that he can shoot from his eyes that's
without the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet and then after her he puts a
clear block of force around Cyclops his
head causing him to suffocate and that's
how he does quickly after that he rips
the insides out of vision much like he
did in infinity war honestly and that's
how he does then cloak manages to
capture Thanos inside his cloak but
unfortunately the Infinity Gauntlet is
just too powerful and causes him to
explode and then Thanos's woman
terr axia rips the head off of Iron Man
and she is definitely not as strong as
Thanos physically speaking so we know if
she can rip his head off
Thanos could rip his head off too but
she doesn't stop there she actually
beats spider-man to death with a rock
and while she finishes off Spidey Thor
comes and Thanos turns him to glass
right before Thanos is about to break
the glass Thor
Nova attacks Stannis Nova then suffers
an interesting death because Thanos uses
the power of the Infinity Gauntlet to
turn him into Legos and to add insult to
injury Thanos then steps on the Legos
and then Tanis delivers the final blow
by breaking the glass Thor effectively
killing him and then what's kind of
interesting is quasi shows up and he
kind of has the mantle of Captain Marvel
at this time he has many similar powers
and he also has the quantum bands but is
still no match for
Thanos Thanos doesn't even use the
Infinity Gauntlet on him he simply uses
his laser beam eyes again and kazars
done and last ago is good old Captain
America and like I said
danos doesn't even use the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet he simply backhands
him and kills him this is all pretty
impressive considering he kills most of
the mightiest heroes but if you ask me
he wasn't really trying and I don't
think he was really trying an infinity
war either I mean he may have tried a
little bit throughout Doctor Strange
definitely put up a good fight but as we
saw when he wanted things to end he
ended them Iron Man wailed on him and
barely made him bleed and when Thanos
decided that he had enough with Iron Man
he ended it and although I do realize
that the MCU is definitely different in
the comics it seems like we still really
haven't seen the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet in the MCU so going back to the
Infinity Gauntlet series it's super
impressive that Thanos defeated all
these mighty heroes but I mean they
barely put up a fight what's really
impressive is when after all these
heroes are defeated the cosmic entities
show up not only are the cosmic entities
here the astral deities but two
Celestials are with them as well and
once they all show up they just go at it
they just start to battle and the battle
is so intense and magnifying and
powerful that The Watcher of the
universe is just sitting there watching
in horror as you can see here The
Watcher expresses his horror by saying
the powers unleashed in the initial
clash are beyond the power of words to
describe many of the etics of nature
fall victim to the assault
I sense near collapse along the entire
spectrum of reality fear grows within my
heart the fear that I am witnessing the
end of the universe so you have these
cosmic beings who basically make up
parts of the universe fighting with
somebody who has control over the
universe
so it's just chaos the fight between
Thanos and these cosmic beings is just
basically destroying the universe solar
systems are being destroyed billions of
people who live inside these solar
systems on these
are dying all because just the power of
the cosmic beans and the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet is just so much it
truly is a battle for the galaxy that is
perfectly demonstrated when the two
Celestials that are there fight Thanos
the two Celestials basically they just
take a ton of planets that are in the
surrounding solar systems line them up
and just start chucking them all at
Thanos and it's crazy because some of
these planets have life on them and it
even says in there the fact that some of
these worlds are inhabited by sentient
life cannot be a consideration in this
galaxy spanning contests but even this
attack by the Celestials is no match for
the Infinity Gauntlet and it says with
the speed of thought their menacing
potential is neutralized by power
without limit speaking of the Infinity
Gauntlet and then Kronos who controls
time comes and tries to bury him within
different layers of time but it doesn't
matter because Thanos has the Infinity
Gauntlet and one of the Infinity stones
is the time stone so Santos actually
controls time so not even Chronos is
enough to stop him and then you have the
big guys that come in Galactus and the
stranger attack and it says the sheer
intensity of Galactus the stranger and
eons Blitzkrieg catches the mad Titan
off-balance yet it is but a minor
setback for Thanos one that can be
overcome with a mere wish basically
anything that Thanos thinks becomes
reality with the Infinity Gauntlet he
then wraps up by defeating mistress love
and sire hate so Thanos battles and
defeats and captures all of these cosmic
entities all of which could easily
destroy the Avengers the x-men the
Fantastic Four any of the superheroes
all of these cosmic beings could just
simply squash them and Thanos has
defeated them all but if that wasn't
enough at the end of it all eternity
shows up eternity is the actual
embodiment of all there is eternity is
the collective consciousness of all the
living things in the universe he is
every living thing and every living
thing is
him so he basically controls everything
that is in existence but even eternity
knows just how strong the Infinity
Gauntlet is he even says right before
they go into battle then let us see
which our mighty being truly has the
tight grip on the fabric of what is so
this is a fight for the control of the
reality that they're in and for the
universe so they start fighting and it's
just this huge blast of energy that's
all anybody who's watching sees and at
the end no one knows who's winning or is
going to win
but after all of the energy is dispersed
we see that Thanos has imprisoned
eternity that is how strong the Infinity
Gauntlet is the Infinity Gauntlet was
strong enough to defeat multiple cosmic
beings two Celestials and eternity
itself and again I'm not saying that
they're going to give the Infinity
Gauntlet all of this power in the MCU
but you can tell just how strong it is
so in my opinion in Avengers 4 if they
don't do something to get Thanos away
from the Infinity stones they have no
chance unless the plot leaked rumors are
true and they go throughout time in
different realities collecting their own
Infinity stones and make their own
Infinity Gauntlet and then we'd have a
battle of Infinity gauntlets
which honestly I think would be awesome
and is the way that I think they should
take it but we'll have to wait and see
so there you have it there is a brief
overview of just how strong the Infinity
Gauntlet
is in the Infinity Gauntlet series I'll
ask sort of the same question do you
think any of the Avengers or Captain
Marvel is strong enough to take on
Thanos with the Infinity Gauntlet let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
if you enjoyed the video please hit that
thumbs up button and be sure to
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this and to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 Marvel DC and all thanks
super thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]